people around the world who are fighting
for equality
and and i really mean this they are
totally annoyed at the new york
hollywood west hollywood gays who
who raise a lot of money for black tie
events
and aren't doing a thing to help our
brothers and sisters in lebanon
who are getting arrested
i went to the 1993 march on washington
for
uh when when bill clinton and al gore
had
taken over and that march was incredible
because they're
i i'm going to get the number wrong and
somebody's going to come out they'll
come at you yeah
i think it was like a million people
right gays and lesbians and
straight supporters all came out to
washington and marched
and it was dramatic in that i think it
was at that point
that that things became political on
gays and lesbians and
and the lgbt movement um before then
we kind of all were on the outs and so
we were together we when washington you
know people
republicans and democrats were not
making this the wedge issue
but i will say that that the march on
washington
um left our community with a sense
of we just want equality and if you go
back to that march dave
the mantra was tolerance
and diversity we recognized that
other people were not going to agree
with us and
our whole request our ask was
just embrace diversity we know you don't
you don't agree with everything that
that
you know we stand for but let's just be
tolerant of each other
so remember hate is not a family value
was this whole thing
yeah now the the entire leadership of
the lgbt movement in washington dc
is all about cancel culture and
absolutely pushing people out of the
argument to say
i'm i don't even want to be friends with
you if you voted for trump
or you're a gay conservative i can't
even fathom being friends with you well
now they also want to take your gayness
away right so they'll write articles
that famous article
in out magazine about how peter thiel is
not gay
enough because it's because it's not who
you have sex with or who you love that
makes you gay it's actually a political
way of thinking that makes you gay which
is which is why glad
um has this whole like immigration
and and it's a movement beyond anything
that has to do
with gays and lesbians and i think it's
an ex
they're trying to survive right well is
that just the cops need a certain amount
of crime type of thing it's like we got
equal rights and not to say
everything is perfect but i work i work
around the world let me tell you
it's pretty people around the world who
are
fighting for equality and and i really
mean this
they are totally annoyed at the new york
hollywood west hollywood gays yeah who
who raise a lot of money for black tie
events
and aren't doing a thing to help our
brothers and sisters in lebanon
who are getting arrested or look what
happened in zambia
they literally prosecuted two two guys
for being gay and
and the court said oh no we're doing
this because they're gay they didn't
make up some pedophilia thing i don't
know but if you say something about that
you're somehow racist right or you're
something like that because you're
pushing your values but some values are
better than others
that must be the number one thing you
have to fight all the time right at the
u.s or
over the years at the u.n that you had
to fight that now as an ambassador
well i'm now fighting this thing at the
state department where when it comes to
the decriminalization campaign
um so you're you're spearheading this
thing right i'm spearheading this thing
uh there's 69 countries that criminalize
homosexuality
10 will kill you for being gay and
we've launched a process we've done a
whole bunch we're trying to stay
out of the media in terms of telling
them every little thing
uh because the media is pretty hostile
to something like this
uh we've we've we're making great media
is pretty hostile to something like
decriminalizing
from the trump administration right
honestly i know we'll get to that i was
about to tell you a second ago that
we've talked for about a half hour or so
and until about a minute ago
the t-word had not come up yet which i
think is a record yeah
but so we'll get to that in a second but
sorry go ahead but but the
decriminalization campaign um
we're making so much progress uh
granted this is going to be a long fight
uh trying to convince 69 countries to do
a change in domestic laws to
to not criminalize homosexuality and
that's all this is a step one is just to
work on criminalization others are
working on step two through twenty
i i felt the need to do step one because
when i look around the world step one
wasn't really being pushed
i've been working with no this is going
to be bad because they're probably going
to go after them but
i've been working with stuart milk of
the harvey milk foundation who's
fantastic
who's totally focused on this problem
and so what we're trying to do is to
have 69 different uh campaigns basically
because you've got to work with the
local
community remarkable stories that i
could just go in
over and over that i don't because i
don't want to highlight it and
scare people away that are working in
these countries but suffice to say
um this was a fight that needed to
happen that was not happening
and right now i have to face at the
state department
resistance from people who don't want
americans or westerners
to go into other countries and take a
stand for
the decriminalization campaign because
literally there are countries that
believe
that the west and specifically america
have
imported into their country being gay
and so
they're like oh no no american should
talk about this because you're going to
emphasize my position back is
that's the stupidest idea that americans
brought in
the gay right they're going to gay
people before america it's only about
200-year thing
right so i'm not gonna actually be
silent on that and participate in
letting them silence me because they've
got some crazy conspiracy
theory i'm gonna bust the conspiracy
theory wide open and say
you're wrong how do you decide though
when to use
extra pressure to get a country to do
something because i know as generally as
a conservative and from what i know
about you
you don't love the idea of go of telling
countries what to do like it's not
really like in the conservative ethos
right and yet i understand you want
people to be free so how do you decide
when we can apply more pressure
yeah i don't one i get one every
interview
that's the one i would say that i have
this philosophy that
that as a diplomat
i am working at the state department and
i have to be successful in order to
avoid
war because if you have diplomats who
are not successful
that file of a problem gets transferred
over to the pentagon
and they don't negotiate they just solve
the problem
and so i firmly believe that diplomats
should be at the forefront of pushing
and prodding
and demanding talks and demanding that
we have a table
to to you know air our grievances on
even before like if we're planning to
bomb if if the if dod is ready to
to attack i would hope that we have
brave diplomats that are saying wait a
minute
i got one more chance let's sit down
let's try the diplomacy thing so
you know i get hit constantly for oh
you're undiplomatic or you're too tough
and i thought
that's what you want in the diplomat
because you want to have somebody that's
working hard to avoid war through talk
through through pushing and prodding
rather than
transferring the file over and and you
know having a problem solved through
military action has some of that been
tough for you though because you used to
fight on twitter more or be more of like
a battler there
where you know you've you're an
ambassador now you're a guy in a hoodie
you've
calmed it down a little bit i still
think that i pick my fights
um i i don't feel like i've backed off
what i do think is um that that i want
to make sure that someone is out
in that fight and so i look to see you
know like on a
on a media bias issue i still get
really uh charged up if
the group think in washington or the
political circles is one way and
nobody's challenging that
i'm willing to jump in i don't care if i
have the title of ambassador i'm still
going to jump in and try to to push and
correct the record where i see fit
if others are doing it and thank god
you're in there to do it
uh then sometimes i can little ground
support yeah i can let it go and look
for the next problem
yeah um can you talk a little bit about
just generally what the state of the un
is and what it was like to be there and
you know that so many people think that
it's like
this sort of perfect thing that the
countries come together and
figure out what's right for everybody
like they love the idea of it more than
i think functionally how it works right
or does not work
well first of all the uh
i always try to correct people that that
the u.n doesn't really exist the u.n is
member states right so when somebody
says oh the u.n
says no i always say the u.n doesn't say
no
members at the u.n maybe russia and
china got together in the security
council and said no
but the u.n doesn't take a position and
so
i i try to not just reflexively blame oh
the u.n
stopped something because it's really
member country so that's the first thing
the second thing is is the u.n does not
work unless the u.s
is leading it whether it's the world
food program
unicef undp you know the development
programs
whatever it is the u.s has to be there
otherwise the u.n does not work
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell